thanks kendall it is now time for this
week's pet project amy lee joins us from
the nspca and she brought along someone
who needs a safe and caring home i
understand
this is gigi amy right this is
she she
oh my gosh she's so loving she's
adorable
and i think you were cutting out a
little bit this is obviously a pit bull
for anyone who doesn't know
she is well she's she's actually a
velvet hippo if you will
because i think she's got the cutest
bunny ear but she's
really truly a gentle soul she's an old
soul she's a 10 year old girl that just
wants to give you kisses crash on your
couch go on walks with you
i mean she loves giving kisses she
definitely um
wants to be with with people she loves
being with people um
she's got energy i love her how do you
take care of gigi what what families
would be best for gigi yeah absolutely
so she would love to be in a home with
adults and with teens just because she's
a senior girl
um just so somebody can just you know
attend to her needs as an older dog but
she's really spunky she's on a
fish-based diet she's got a little bit
of allergies but
other than that really she just wants to
love she wants to be
in your company all the time look how
cute she is oh my gosh
gigi i'm a fan of gigi so what are you
guys doing right now during the pandemic
of course tell people how they can adopt
and
and get more information absolutely so
what you would do is actually just visit
our website at nevadaspca.org
and you would book an appointment to
speak with an adoption counselor over
the phone and they're going to go
through
everything about her send you photos
videos anything to kind of
make sure that we have the right fit and
there it's all curbside so
the dog would come out to you gigi would
need to be the only pet
um in your home but we really hope to
find her a loving family because she
really deserves it she's so sweet
me too i have a feeling someone's gonna
a lot of people are gonna pull up
to visit gigi so thank you so much amy
all right if you're interested in
adopting a pet go to nevadaspca.org or
just call them at 702-873-7722 we'll be
right back